President Obama's Secretary of Defense
before his appointment he worked for 11
previous defense secretaries in both
Democratic and Republican
administrations he was recently named
director of the Belfair Belfer Center at
the Harvard Kennedy School is also
associated with innovation at MIT ash
Carter good morning good morning
let me just ask the question with
respect to this administration what more
can they do in Syria to make a
difference
well the Assad regime you saw what
happened recently that is Bashar Assad
that is an atrocity and the Russians are
enabling that and remember when the
Russians came in Charlie you remember
this the Russians said that they were
going to do what they ought to have done
which is to promote facilitate a
political transition in which Assad is
moved out the structures of the Syrian
state not the regime but some basics of
governance remain and the Syrian
opposition becomes part of the
government and restores this country to
the decency that its people deserve they
didn't do that instead they fueled the
civil war so what can we do well I for
one thing right now is I think that
additional sanctions on Russia which a
number of my Hill are calling for is
appropriate and the Russians have
responsibility for this and they didn't
do what they said they were going to do
responsibility meaning they carried out
the attack I don't know they've enabled
I don't have any more reason to say that
specifically it's clear that the Assad
regime did and they are enablers and
supporters they didn't come in to end
the civil war they joined the civil war
on the side of Russia all side but the
Trump administration says that the Obama
administration missed a great
opportunity to solve the crisis in Syria
what's your response to when you hear
that III wasn't Secretary of Defense at
that time but we are where we are today
and that's where I'm realistic about
where I was the Secretary of Defense and
I thought it was important that we keep
the pressure on the Russians to do what
they're supposed to do meanwhile in the
rest of Syria don't forget we have
American troops there today who are very
successfully doing
has to be done which is destroy ISIL
destroy ISIL in Raqqa also Iraq by the
way because in order that's necessary
because those that's not a civil war
they are intent upon attacking Americans
and we need to protect ourselves and we
need to destroy ISIL in Iraq and Syria
because that's where it arose and we
need to destroy the fact and the idea
that there can be an Islamic state based
upon isil's ideology so that's important
and we're doing that at the same time in
the civil war our approach has been to
try to promote an end to the civil war
and not to fuel a civil war that's not
what not to take out Bashar Assad well
again what the Russians said they were
going to do was move Assad aside and the
members of the regime five days before
this attack happened president Trump
abandoned the goal of pressuring Assad
to leave power that was a shift in US
policy do you think that that sent a
message that allowed Assad to carry out
this attack I can't say that I this is
Assad's responsibility I think it is
important for us to have clarity about
our policy and consistent that
consistency in the enunciation of our
policy you talk about North Yemen was no
right to that now you know a lot about
no nuclear policy do you believe the
North Koreans now have the capacity to
deliver a nuclear weapon to America's
coast I'm certain they're trying to get
that charlie but I mean how close are
they because some are saying they're
this close i I believe that they are
intent upon getting there and what we
need to do about that and are doing
about that we've long anticipated that
is we we stay one step ahead of them
that's Charlie why we improved our
missile defenses of our new territory
and their quality to protect ourselves
that's why we're deploying the so called
THAAD system in South Korea which is so
important that's why we have 28,000
troops on the Korean Peninsula
so from job one I'd like to see the
Chinese especially turn the North
Koreans around for reasons I can explain
I don't have not optimistic about that
but not what we've tried for twenty
years it's worth continuing to try but
in the meantime we have to deter and we
have to defend ourselves we stand strong
in the Korean Peninsula there's troops
there right now as we sit here right now
it's evening there their motto is fight
tonight and of course we don't nobody
wants a war there but it means they're
ready they are ready and if their war
came to the Korean Peninsula I'm first
of all confident that we would win we
would destroy North Korea's military and
destroy the North Korean regime but it
is an intensity of violence that the
world has not seen since the last Korean
War it's a very congested area around
the DMZ many many civilians would be
killed in the process in this process so
it's not something you can deal with
lightly but we are ready President Trump
has a big meeting of course today
tomorrow this weekend with President Xi
of China the last missile test that the
North Koreans launched we saw the
secretary of state state Tillerson issue
a statement that says the u.s. has
spoken enough about North Korea we have
no further comment as the u.s. spoken
enough about North Korea did you find
that statement unusual well I think
what's important is what we is to act
and I mean that we've long been clear in
opposing North Korean nuclear and
missile but also their general
aggression and provocative posture on
the Korean Peninsula I think that much
is is clear what isn't clear to me is
whether the Chinese will ever do
exercise what they they uniquely have
which is carrots and sticks that could
influence the behavior of Kim jong-un
you know I've worked on this for a long
time so why do you why did the Chinese
not do that I think there are two
reasons Charlie both of which they fear
the near-term more than the far term a
lot of us are like that and it's a
natural tendency but they know this is
trouble in the long run and select the
Frog boiling in the pot they haven't
jumped and the reason they haven't
jumped to your question is twofold one
is they don't want to see a collapse of
North Korea and they don't want to see a
war on the Korean Peninsula because they
know that that would result in a unified
Korea quite likely oh it linked with the
United States we're out of time but
remember the president the United States
Donald Trump said if the Chinese are not
prepared to go with us we're prepared to
go alone I believe today will be they
said he was going to be dealing with the
Chinese on that as well as very
important economic trade and other
issues trade and other issues thank you
thank you good to be good to see you
like